so the Mecca Medina distinction seems to
be very I would say both complicated and
problematic because so so tell me if I'm
wrong okay because my understanding is
that Muhammad spent most of the part of
his life that was associated with the
establishment of Islam in Medina and
northern Mecca and that it wasn't until
he went to Medina that Islam actually
became a force so back in Mecca although
his doctrine appears to have been let's
say more peaceful it was also much less
successful as a as a both a religious
and a political movement so then he left
Mecca and I believe under pressure from
the inhabitants at least to some degree
moved to Medina and then that's when
Islam became more more rep more
revolutionary and expansive and so what
do you see now I know that it isn't
universally accepted among the Islamic
community that that Mecca Medina
distinction is a reasonable one to make
because of course the presumption is
that there's an essential unity of
thought across the doctrines but but
given given your interpretation and I've
read the similar interpretation among
other among other people do you see what
you see is hopeful within the Islamic
community with regards to bridging the
gap between the say the earlier works so
to speak of Muhammad and the later the
later more or revolutionary element of
the of his actions and his faith is
there a way that that can be reconciled
well so dividing up Muslims into Mecca a
set of Mecca set of Medina and modifiers
that's not of course an official
distinction or it's not accepted
anywhere
you really want to get to you know who
which individuals which was loose at war
with us and should we be worried about
what's what about the vast majority
peaceful Muslim what about these other
Muslims were speaking up you know what
kind of labels we were given them if you
said in the works of the Islamists what
you will notice I read this as a Muslim
what I think that was the first thing
that I noticed is that they're selected
and in their selection you justify their
oxygen they share invoke Muhammad's
legacy in Mecca because as a Muslim if
my sister tells me I am
you've missed a pair you need to get up
and say I won't involve some verse for
Mecca and say oh come on
my relationship with a lot things
intimate and unique it's none of your
business to tell him what to do and then
she will come up with some other advice
or some other third saying well but it's
mighty people command I can control and
all alone will go so this is within a
most limited paranoid but then the
medina Muslims they extend and wrists so
it is fight me and I'm not the only one
the others full of like Muhammad Ali
they are very honest fellows who must
see a way of preserving Islam edition of
the culture as a civilization and at the
same time putting to bear this is
violent he fights for violating courses
within Islam if you try and do that then
you're going to see you're going to make
a list of the concepts they decreased
that we really don't have any problem
look like people being told to pray five
times a day or this is metal or Castille
amount of Ramadan and all sorts of you
know latest features I only don't have a
problem with that and when I look at
where all of that is concentrated that's
the method in the early days in Medina
as you said elephant into a political
philosophy it becomes analytic feed
Mohammed wages was good he needs them in
that's promised me and that's exactly
when Islam become successful and
Islamist of today are trying to if
they're trying to emulate that power and
then say so explicitly invited and they
are their power to be you know to be
emulating on the previously so that's I
think where I say you know the Mecca
Medina is problematic is an entire home
classification that we applied in social
sciences has its problems but this
resource of simplifies because it
focuses attention where it should read
okay so you see this as an externally
applied category system essentially the
channel that's useful for for for
outsiders who are trying to assess the
situation to determine who it is that
you're dealing with that might be
regarded as an ally and who it is that
you're dealing with it might be regarded
as a foe so to speak and that would be
on the more militant end of things
that's reasonable way of looking at it
that's reasonable that's a reasonable
way of looking at it but also if you
take the moderate versus extreme
classification or categorization that
has become commonplace it doesn't tell
you when we look at moderate we think of
people who are not using violence
whereas if you look at Medina you will
see that there are hundreds of thousands
of Muslims who do not apply violence now
but who do preach violence and they do
reach the medina like Isis and they
believe that Sharia should be instituted
and in places where they get where you
get a majority of these non violent
media types then suddenly it is half
apply and enforces Sharia law so I think
in the terms moderate and extreme are
just not good enough they don't cover
the right well and they also don't they
don't also seem to bear any relationship
to the internal dynamics of the faith
itself so that that's also problematic
okay so you have to keep going back to
the theology have to keep going back to
the internal debates among Muslims how
to move on and how to relate to the
festival so I personally think Mecca and
Medina is much more useful as a tool as
an external conceptual framework for
understanding the problem we face is
Islam then extreme versus first water
it's only you know all the other terms
that we have